euh on passe tout de suite comme chaque
jour cette semaine je vous propose un un
gros plan sur l'un des chantiers du
gouvernement l'une des réformes lancées
hier on parlait énergie zoom sur la
réforme de l'assurance chômage ce soir
le ministre du Travail vient d'envoyer
au partenaires sociaux le texte pour
encadrer leur discussion le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est que ça passe mal
chez certains par exemple le secrétaire
général de la CGT écoutez c'est ça les
lettres de cadrage ça porte bien son nom
vous voyez le cadre il est tout petit
donc on vous dit voilà le résultat qu'on
veut débrouillez-vous pour trouver
évidemment la négociation est déjà
tronquée et ça donne un bon prétexte au
gouvernement pour dire et vous l'avez
déjà entendu sur d'autres négociations
bah ils arrivent pas se mettre d'accord
donc c'est à nous de prendre cette loi
ils vise notamment à prolonger la
précédente réforme de l'assurance
chômage en réforme qui sanctionne les
contrats courts alors la bonne nouvelle
c'est que les entreprises signent plus
de CDI mais certaines catégories sont
perdantes reportage tout de suite avec
cette guide confér frontières rencontré
par Jérôme Rabier et Xavier Montel
on va terminer cette visite du Marais
par la place des Vosges c'est à nouveau
je le nom était donné par Napoléon après
la Révolution française Bernie Andersen
et guide conférencier interprète depuis
un peu moins de 15 ans cette danoise
d'origine passionnée d'histoire et
d'histoire de l'art a choisi sur le tard
ce métier par vocation
les obtient grâce à des agences
touristiques mais la réforme de
l'assurance chômage est venue
bouleverser cette activité qui jusque-là
était salarié mais j'étais salarié à la
mission avec des CDD d'usage
à partir du moment où il a été question
de taxer les CDD
et bien les agences elles ont été un
petit peu plus frileux et maintenant
elles imposent
où elle on va dire qu'elle ne travaille
que avec des guides qui seront le qui
ont le statut de auto-entrepreneur
je vous souhaite une bonne journée
un changement de statut qu'elle a refusé
elle fait donc appel à une société de
portage salarial pour garder certains
avantages mais ce qui engendre des coups
l'activité est aussi forcément
saisonnière soumise à l'allée
Andersen travaille majoritairement de
mars à novembre jusqu'à présent
[Musique]
puisqu'on savait que on est en ayant
suffisamment travaillé
on pouvait les mois d'hiver bénéficier
de
la location chômage j'ai une baisse de
mon allocation chômage de 47% une baisse
de presque 50% due au nouveau mode de
calcul et pour elle une précarisation de
l'ensemble de la profession qui lui
ferait presque regretter de cette
relancée dans ce métier passion il est
clair
que si j'avais aujourd'hui dix ans de
moins j'aurais fait une reconversion je
n'aurais pas continué dans ce métier là
même si c'est un métier que j'adore
chaque jour est différent c'est vraiment
vraiment un métier que qui m'intéresse
c'est un métier passion comme on dit
mais j'aurais pas non j'aurais pas
persévérer
dans la profession une bonne partie des
guides conférenciers à sauter le pas et
ouvert des statues d'auto-entrepreneurs
disparaissant ainsi des chiffres du
chômage lors des mois non travaillés
fragilisant un peu plus une profession
singulière
la réforme de l'assurance chômage on en
débat tout de suite et je vous présente
mes invités Anne-Sophie elsive bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes chef économiste du
cabinet de conseil BDO France Éric
Hyères bonsoir et bienvenue directeur
département analysé prévisions de l'OFCE
j'accue également Bernard vivier bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi directeur de
l'Institut Supérieur du travail Laetitia
cruppa évidemment est resté à à mes
côtés je commence par cette expression
de métier en tension c'est difficulté de
recrutement pour les entreprises
peut-être pour là aussi faire un peu de
pédagogie on a commencé par de la
pédagogie au début de notre premier
débat comment on peut l'expliquer cette
cette situation elle est assez complexe
il y a plusieurs facteurs mais comment
on peut expliquer donc c'est vrai que là
on a un taux de chômage autour de 7% je
m'appelle normalement le plein d'emploi
c'est 4,5%, c'est pas 7% donc on est au
dessus en France et pourquoi parce qu'on
a un taux d'emploi des jeunes et des
seniors qui est assez faible finalement
donc on a un fort chômage des moins de
25 ans et des plus de 55 ans et donc en
effet avec la reprise de limité on a eu
cette baisse du taux de chômage avec les
difficultés qu'on connaît dans des
secteurs mais on a sur ces catégories là
des personnes et les moins de 25 ans qui
sont vraiment sortis du système scolaire
et les plus de 55 ans aussi parce qu'on
a un âge de départ à la retraite qui est
on va dire donc légalement de 62 ans
qu'on qui est plus proche que ce qu'on
peut voir dans notre pays européen et
bien beaucoup de personnes qui sont dans
des situations de prêtres ou dans des
situations de ne pas retrouver un emploi
et qui du coup crée souvent leur
situation leur propre entreprise ou se
mettent en auto-entrepreneur et donc là
pour vraiment arriver
on se dit il y a enfin tous les thés moi
j'ai vu des des affiches
emploi proposé jamboche venez travailler
dans mon entreprise enfin partout et
dans tous les secteurs donc comment
expliquer ce chiffre que vous nous avez
donné 2300 000 chômeurs inscrits à Pôle
emploi et puis des entreprises qui
arrivent pas à côté parce qu'il y a une
dichotomie entre la formation et l'offre
d'emploi et la demande et donc les
publics qui ne trouvent pas un emploi
qui sont durablement hors du système de
l'emploi c'est pas forcément donc
inscrits qu'on a dans les statistiques
c'est pas forcément les personnes qui
pourront demain
occuper les emplois dont on a besoin
parce que il y a la formation et qu'il
n'y a pas le capital humain qui
correspond Éric et IR c'est structurel
c'est provisoire un peu des deux il faut
faire attention alors d'abord difficulté
de recrutement ne veut pas dire pas de
recrutement au contraire on n'a jamais
autant recruter en France donc attention
souvent on a l'impression qu'on ne
trouve pas on pourrait on trouve pas non
vous voyez aujourd'hui quand on regarde
le niveau d'activité d'accord il est peu
ouprou celui qui prévalait en 2019 donc
au niveau de la crise 09 au-dessus c'est
quand même pas beaucoup et compte tenu
des gains de productivité non en
produire la même chose qu'il y a deux
ans et demi on aurait dû avoir moins de
salariés pour produire la même chose que
qui qui a 2 ans et demi or il y a
beaucoup plus on aurait dû faire à peu
près - 1 d'emplois on a fait 3,8
d'emplois en plus donc vous voyez ça
c'est quand même assez une singularité
vous dites comment se fait-il qu'avec
cette façon de chômage on est autant
difficile de recrutement moi ma question
c'est comment se fait-il avec aussi peu
d'activités on est autant dans quoi et
voyez et c'est les phénomènes ce qu'on
appelle de speed limite c'est-à-dire que
quand tout le monde recrute bah c'est
plus difficile de recruter c'est sûr que
en période de crise il y a pas de
difficulté personne ne recrute il y a
pas dit donc ça c'est plutôt une
explication conjoncturelle d'accord
aujourd'hui et alors la peut-être que
l'idée ça serait de dire que ceux
normalement vous voyez dans dans il y a
beaucoup de rotation c'est à dire qu'il
y a beaucoup de personnes qui perdent
leur emploi et il y a beaucoup de
contrats qui sont signés on a souvent ce
chiffre en tête 10000 contrat signés
chaque jour 10000 contrats qui sont
rompu chaque jour bon il y a des jours
un peu en positifs des jours un peu en
négatif c'est ça qui est qui fait que
l'emploi progresse ou pas aujourd'hui
les entreprises qui devraient
normalement se séparer de leur de leurs
collaborateurs beaucoup moins donc c'est
ce qu'on appelle un peu les entreprises
zombies vous voyez des entreprises qui
auraient dû faire faillite pendant la
crise qui ne font pas faillite ah mais
elles gardent des effectifs en leur sein
alors que normalement ces personnes là
sont au chômage et donc sont les
employés des entreprises qui recrutent
vous avez aussi beaucoup d'absence et
donc quand vous avez beaucoup d'absence
liées à la covid et ben les entreprises
font une petite réserve en disant ah du
jour au lendemain cette personne ne peut
ne pas venir j'ai besoin donc d'avoir
troisième point et troisième point qui
est important c'est que les carnets de
commandes aujourd'hui n'ont jamais été
aussi plein généralement les chaînes
d'entreprise les industriels ont deux
mois de production dans leur carnet de
commandes là c'est 6 donc il se disent
tiens ça va repartir parce que j'ai
beaucoup d'activités pour l'instant je
peux pas produire parce que le problème
d'approvisionnement mais le jour où ça
se libère donc je garde mes salariés et
donc ça fait qu'il y a beaucoup
d'emplois et donc des difficultés à
recruter parce que les entreprises qui
cherchent elles ont un peu plus de
difficultés à recruter est-ce qu'il y a
certains secteurs qui sont
désertés alors bon on va poser la
question à Bernard vivier qui a pas
encore pris la parole oui bien sûr et
des secteurs en difficulté par rapport à
d'autres oui bien sûr d'abord tous les
secteurs ou nous n'avons pas eu encore
le temps de former des personnes d'abord
des secteurs anciens on pense au métier
de la santé mais aussi des secteurs ou
la formation n'a pas encore mis sur le
marché du travail les personnes
compétentes donc oui également des
secteurs comme alors on en parle très
souvent l'hôtellerie restauration où il
n'y a pas que l'ajustement entre le
salaire demandé le salaire proposé il y
a d'autres questions fondamentales
lourdes le transport le logement
les horaires de travail les jours de
travail deux jours consécutifs de repos
hebdomadaire et une profession comme les
métiers de l'hôtellerie à cet été
constaté qu'il y avait à peu près 150
000 emplois qui allaient manquer
d'ailleurs nous connaissons tous des
restaurateurs qui n'ont pas ouvert
pendant trois semaines ou 15 jours parce
qu'il y avait pas les personnes pour
faire fonctionner le restaurant et cette
profession a établi un contrat avec
l'équivalent de Pôle emploi en Tunisie
et ça a été très astucieux pour faire
venir des saisonniers de Tunisie dans
des conditions de rémunération des
conditions sociales dignes équivalentes
de celles des Français premièrement mais
des Français qui eux-mêmes ont été
revalorisés notamment la question du
transport du logement et des horaires de
travail ça sera pour la prochaine saison
je crois l'accord qui est passé avec
avec le Pôle Emploi tunisien j'avais cru
comprendre ça au début de cette année et
ça a eu des premiers effets d'accord les
premiers effets des cet été je vous
propose un premier chiffre qui est
frappant 95% des dirigeants
d'entreprises affirment avoir rencontré
des difficultés à recruter au cours des
6 derniers mois et c'est ce que confirme
le président du Medef Geoffroy route
Béziers on l'écoute
le sujet numéro un de préoccupation des
chefs d'entreprise c'est le recrutement
d'ailleurs pas besoin d'aller à une AG
du bénef tous ceux d'entre vous qui sont
allés j'espère pour vous au restaurant
ou à l'hôtel cet été ont pu le constater
la pénurie de salariés elle est
absolument partout au fond les seuls
chefs d'entreprise qui n'ont pas de
problème de recrutement c'est ceux qui
recrutent pas
il y a plus vous savez les fameux
métiers en tension il y a plus de
métiers en tension car tous les métiers
sont tension alors Laetitia on parle
souvent depuis plusieurs mois de grandes
démissions on va rappeler que
l'expression vient des États-Unis oui
j'ai un petit peu honte de mon accent
voilà je pardonnez-moi mais ça s'appelle
The Great rising nation c'est pas le
phénomène en fait consiste à quitter son
emploi du jour au lendemain voilà on
claque la porte ça a commencé en 2021
évidemment dans plein de pandémie covid
ou finalement les Américains se sont
posés des questions entre leur vie
privée leur vie professionnelle on fait
d'autres d'autres choix et c'est un
phénomène d'ampleur Thomas puisque en
2021 38 millions d'Américains ont claqué
la porte c'est un record depuis l'année
2000 et ce phénomène a été amplifié par
un autre phénomène que l'on connaît bien
ici celui des réseaux sociaux parce que
beaucoup d'Américains ont mis en scène
leur démission notamment sur Tik Tok
avec des millions de vues à la clé
regardez un exemple
patron voilà ma démission mais tu es un
bon élément et puis on t'a augmenté de
5% cette année c'est bien le problème
vous me payez moins pour la même
quantité de travail et puis vous ne me
payez certainement pas à la hauteur de
ma valeur sur le marché mais comment ça
on te paye moins on t'a augmenté 5% ça
ne couvre même pas l'inflation et
d'ailleurs j'ai une autre proposition
30% mieux payée donc soit vous vous
alignez bon je vais voir ce qu'on peut
faire je vais discuter avec les RH ok
j'ai compris je vais commencer à
transmettre mes dossiers à Bob ok donc
certaines vidéos un peu comme celle-ci
ont été vous l'avez divisionné plusieurs
millions de fois alors en France
maintenant est-ce qu'on a mesuré de
great rising nation on n'est pas à la
hauteur des États-Unis évidemment il ne
dépasse déjà depuis longtemps sur
beaucoup de domaines mais il y a c'est
vrai qu'il y a un décrochage par exemple
en juillet 2021 le nombre de démissions
a augmenté de 20% par rapport à juillet
2019 mais alors mi-août direction à
statistique du ministère du Travail
publie une petite étude ou finalement il
démontre que plus qu'une grande
démission c'est un grand turnover c'est
une grande rotation pourquoi parce que
ceux qui quittent leur emploi on
retrouve un dans les six mois 8
démissionnaires sur 10 retrouvent un
autre emploi dans les six mois donc faut
relativiser le phénomène c'est ça oui
alors c'est vrai que nous aussi on a eu
peut-être pas Tic-Toc mais en tout cas
tous les magazines les quotidiens qui
ont fait leur une cet été sur la grande
démission enfin on avait l'impression
que c'était vraiment la menace qui
allait arriver à la rentrée donc on
relativise bien sûr mais il y a quand
même une question qui reste en suspens
on l'a abordé avec vous monsieur est-ce
que finalement le rôle du travail et la
place que l'on donne au travail nonovie
n'est pas revu par tout le monde et à
chaque échelon aussi de l'échelle
sociale pas uniquement les nantis
finalement dans ces dans nos sociétés
occidentales puisque la Fondation Jean
Jaurès a fait une étude
et c'est très clair le vraiment le le
fossé est très clair entre les deux
chiffres en 1990 les Français pensaient
à 60% que leur travail était très
important aujourd'hui ils sont 24 %.
alors il y a beaucoup d'éléments qui
sont vraiment intéressants à analyser et
je veux entendre votre expertise
là-dessus parce qu'il y a il y a le
phénomène effectivement né de la crise
covid et puis il y a aussi le phénomène
né d'une transition écologique et voilà
et beaucoup d'entreprises sont en train
de changer de modèle être obligé de
réinventer leur modèle économique donc
de réinventer des emplois etc etc je
voudrais commencer sur la quête de sens
en quelque sorte Anne-Sophie alcif c'est
le point de départ de cette grande
démission dont on parle c'est toujours à
l'oeuvre c'est toujours à l'oeuvre c'est
vrai qu'avec le covid ce qui a été
inédit c'est qu'on avait du temps et que
tout s'est arrêté très souvent et c'est
pour ça que les économies sont
interrogés mais c'est aussi les
sociologues c'est aussi des psychologues
c'est vraiment toute la science sociale
qui devrait être questionné sur le sujet
tout d'un coup on a eu du temps mais du
temps pour tous c'est-à-dire que tout
s'est arrêté donc ça c'est quelque chose
qui est complètement fou et donc
forcément c'est ce temps qu'on a eu à
créer beaucoup de prise de conscience on
s'en souvient on parlait pas déjà de la
fin de l'abondance en tout cas de vivre
différemment de du monde d'après on se
souvient qu'on avait eu beaucoup de
débats là-dessus et c'est vrai que ça ça
a fait que vous êtes beaucoup questionné
sur votre activité alors que d'habitude
vous êtes un peu entre guillemets dans
le guidon vous les semaines s'enchaînent
et donc vous avez pas de réflexion
vraiment sur votre sur votre parcours
donc ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
était très important notamment chez les
plus jeunes générations en disant est-ce
que mon travail est-ce que ce que je
fais au quotidien a vraiment un sens
dans toutes ces transitions on voit
risque de guerre pandémie et transition
écologique où je me situe là dedans et
est-ce que ça a vraiment du sens en plus
demain on me dit que je peux plus
accumuler acheter plein de choses etc or
là je travaille énormément pour ça donc
est-ce que ça a vraiment encore du sens
donc ça on le voit dans toutes les
enquêtes c'est vraiment important alors
après bien sûr toujours la nuancer parce
que ça dépend beaucoup du niveau
d'études et de votre profession il y a
des gens pendant ces périodes qui
étaient plutôt en plus grande priori
précarité qui avait beaucoup plus de
difficultés donc là c'était pas le même
topo mais en tout cas ça joue beaucoup
et on voit par rapport à l'étude que
vous avez mentionné que ça change tout
c'est à dire que avant le travail
structuré toutes vos vies même vous
aviez quelque part qu'est-ce que vous
faites et cetera aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup plus qu'est-ce que tu es ou
quelle valeur tu défends et c'est par
rapport à ça qu'on a un clivage beaucoup
moins par rapport à l'emploi et ça et ça
oblige alors il y a le mouvement
existait avant
erikaillir les entreprises aussi à
répondre à cette à cette quête de sens
on sait il y a la loi pacte il y a les
le mouvement des raisons d'être les
entreprises à mission qui prend vraiment
de l'ampleur c'est aussi ça existait
encore une fois avant la crise covid
mais ça c'est accéléré on va dire depuis
c'est une réponse à cette quête de sens
dire voilà à quoi sert mon entreprise
dans la société comme ça mais salariés
se sentent impliqués d'abord enfin
vraiment le cas français c'est pas le
cas américain c'est à dire que le CAM
américain les salariés sont partis et ne
sont jamais revenus tous là qui me
manque encore des il est taux d'emploi
sont inférieurs aujourd'hui qu'avant la
crise en France non les taux d'emploi
sont supérieurs aujourd'hui donc avant
la crise donc il y a pas de travail qui
a disparu au contraire et ils sont plus
salariés qu’indépendance et le nombre de
salariés qu'augmenter donc vous voyez
c'est pas du tout une grande démission
au contraire il travaille plus par
contre la la quête de sens là oui
potentiellement mais c'est pas les
chiffres de l'INSEE qui peut nous leur
dire c'est plutôt des enquêtes
sociologiques alors avant la crise les
enquêtes parce que j'en vois pas depuis
la crise mais avant la crise qui était
intéressante dans les enquêtes menées
sur 186 pays hein vous voyez que c'était
pas il y avait deux types de questions
il y avait la valeur travail ou est-ce
que vous mettez la valeur travail dans
l'éducation de vos enfants etc bah vous
savez quoi la France et après les 35
heures était tout en haut du classement
tout en haut du classement premier pays
européens pour la valeur travail en
revanche un peu plus loin dans les
questions mais est-ce que vous
épanouissez au travail la France était
de mémoire 179e tout en bas du
classement donc c'est pas est-ce qu'il
faut que je travaille pour vivre
qu'est-ce que je dois inculqué à mes
enfants ça il n'y a pas de problème oui
il faut travailler en revanche est-ce
que je m’épanouis non donc si on me
donne la possibilité de partir je prends
cette possibilité des pré-retraite un
chèque et tu t'en vas là je prends parce
que je ne m'épanouis pas donc c'est là
où effectivement le rôle du manager
c'est en grande partie en France et
c'est d'intéresser son salarié et voyez
ce que nous disent les sociologues c'est
que le salarié le français aujourd'hui
jeune ne veut pas devenir
indépendant il veut devenir autonome ce
qui est un peu différent c'est à dire
que au sein d'une structure pourquoi pas
je désire pas être indépendant et monter
ma propre structure je veux bien être
dans une structure mais je vais être
autonome dans la façon et ben de te
donner mon mon travail sur je m'organise
sur le temps de travail ou est-ce que je
veux travailler chez moi ou au bureau
mais ne t'inquiète pas tu auras au bout
du compte ce que je t'ai promis mais je
dois l'organiser de façon pour terminer
sur ce thème il y a l'aspect
générationnel aussi on l'a vu avec il y
a eu plusieurs vidéos on en a montré
déjà dans cette émission la saison
dernière de jeunes diplômés de plusieurs
grandes écoles qui disent finalement ce
cursus la tout tracé dans un grand
groupe c'est pas pour nous toutes ces
raisons font un bouquet ensemble
aujourd'hui ne boudons pas notre plaisir
le chômage baisse donc naturellement
d'une certaine façon le rapport de force
s'inverse c'est le salarié qui est un
peu plus en situation de choisir c'est
pas nouveau moi je me souviens d'un
syndicaliste de la métallurgie il avait
commencé à travailler à 14 ans au
lendemain de la deuxième guerre mondiale
il me disait il tapait dans les mains il
avait un métier dans les mains et tu
vois quand le taulier utilise ce terme
un peu un peu brutal un taulier c'est un
patron dans un dans un argot quand le
poly me plaît pas moi je m'en vais le
soir au lendemain j'ai trouvé un autre
poste ailleurs bon et et et ils étaient
nombreux à faire ça mais il il avait une
sorte de de fierté c'était le sublime
ouvrier comme on a pu dire dans le passé
c'est-à-dire une fierté bon mais
aujourd'hui on ne travaillent plus avec
la certitude que l'on va faire le même
métier toute sa vie dans la même
entreprise donc forcément c'est pas
forcément un dommage d'ailleurs ce que
on peut considérer que c'est bien
d'avoir la capacité de changer de métier
mais bien sûr et le regard s'inverse
dans un entretien d'embauche une
entreprise qui dirait qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez apporter à l'entreprise en s'en
tenant là il va faire fuir les talents
parce que les futurs talents les talents
disent oui mais et vous qu'est-ce que
vous m'apportez dans mon équilibre vie
professionnelle vie personnelle dans
combien de jours de télétravail ma
formation dans dans le télétravail voilà
et on voit aussi aujourd'hui les
entreprises devoir faire des efforts
pour que le management s'adapte à ces
nouvelles façons de travailler on ne
travaille pas aujourd'hui quand on a 20
25 ans comme on travaillait quand on
avait 20-25 ans il y a 30 ou 40 ans bon
alors je voulais qu'on prenne le temps
voilà de ce de ce constat détailler
merci l'évolution on est d'accord et on
va maintenant ouvrir évidemment la
partie de ce débat il nous reste un peu
plus de 20 minutes consacré à cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage et je
propose à Tam traduit de revenir sur ce
plateau elle doit être juste là
rebonsoir Tam donc ça arrive demain sur
la table du Conseil des ministres c'est
vrai premier volet pour objectif de
prolonger la réforme de juillet 2019
peut-il retour en arrière à l'époque les
partenaires sociaux ne parviennent pas à
se mettre d'accord sur de nouvelles
règles gouvernement prend donc un décret
un décret qui prévoit d'une part de
nouvelles conditions d'indemnisation des
conditions plus dures pour ceux qui
alterne période de travail et période
d'inactivité et puis ce système de bonus
malus pour les entreprises selon
qu'elles ont beaucoup recours à des
contrats courts ou non la suite on se la
rappelle tous on l'a encore tous en tête
c'est bien sûr le covid toutes ces
répercussions sur les entreprises sur
les salariés les confinements et donc
finalement et bien la réforme est
d'abord appliquée partiellement et puis
suspendu et finalement elle
intégralement appliquer qu'à partir
d'octobre 2021 nous avons donc
relativement peu de recul sur ces
nouvelles règles qui ont moins d'un an
et qui arrivent à échéance le 1er
novembre prochain et le gouvernement
veut donc les prolonger jusqu'à fin 2023
pour les nouvelles règles enfin pour les
nouvelles règles d'indemnisation et
jusqu'à fin août 2024 pour les bonus
malus qui s'appliquent dans les
entreprises
le chef de l'État a en tête un nouveau
modèle qui prendrait en compte la
situation économique on ne parle que de
ça depuis le mois de juillet le fameux
modèle canadien quand ça va bien
endurcit les règles quand ça va mal on
lâche du lest c'était d'ailleurs
l'argument que défendait Olivier
dussotte le 27 juillet dernier déjà sur
public Senna écouté
nous sommes dans la situation que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui avec des chefs
d'entreprise qui n'arrivent pas à
recruter avec 7% de chômage un peu plus
et il est logique il est normal
d'inciter à la reprise et d'inciter la
reprise d'activités et puis quand le
marché travaille du travail se dégrade
il est aussi normal que la règle soit
plus protectrice c'est ce que nous
allons discuter cet étonnes avec les
partenaires sociaux pour voir sur quels
critères on détermine quand ça va mieux
et quand ça va moins bien et comment on
détermine ce qui relève de
l'assouplissement ou d'une forme de
durcissement alors le raisonnement ce
qu'est les entreprises auraient du mal à
recruter notamment car les règles
n'incitent pas assez au retour à
l'emploi le patronat est d'accord avec
cette analyse pas les syndicats or c'est
bien aux partenaires sociaux que le
gouvernement entend les séries la patate
chaude le problème très très épineux et
on va mal pour l'instant comment il
pourrait donc se mettre d'accord c'est
plutôt ma langue et oui on va on a
entendu tout à l'heure le patron de la
CGT ou écoutons regardons aussi ce que
dit le patron de la CFDT Laurent Berger
il a déjà averti ça n'a pas de sens ça
relève de la pure idéologie c'est
inefficace nous ne négocierons pas
là-dessus difficile d'être plus clair et
même le patron du Medef qui est d'accord
sur l'analyse Geoffroy route Bézieux il
a déjà jeté l'éponge d'avance il a dit
en substance à quoi ça sert de négocier
si on sait d'avance que ça n'aboutira
pas c'est ce qu'il a expliqué en
substances mais le gouvernement notez-le
a aussi d'autres réformes en tête pour
les prochains mois la gouvernance de
lunédique la création de France travail
qui doit remplacer Pôle emploi mais
aussi et surtout la réforme du RSA une
réforme potentiellement explosive et qui
a déjà fait couler beaucoup d'encre
merci beaucoup tant pour toutes ces
explications Anne-Sophie alcif je reste
sur ce sur ce modèle canadien je crois
que ça sale j'ai appris ce mot
aujourd'hui je joue l'avoue le modèle
contracyclique j'ai appris ça donc
module les allocations en fonction de la
conjoncture bon à première vue on se dit
c'est pas absurde qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez ah c'est pas absurde mais ne
marchez du travail canadien n'est pas le
nôtre donc c'est vrai que c'est bien moi
je suis vraiment pour les benchmark
c'est bien mais il faut aussi s'adapter
donc au marché français qui a marché
quand même beaucoup moins flexible ou la
majorité des contrats de travail sont
quand même en CDI et donc c'est assez
difficile donc de dire ça alors bien
évidemment il y a tout ce qui est
ruptures conventionnelle choix de
changer mais vous avez aussi des gens
voilà qui qui sont licenciés même si ça
va bien économiquement parce qu'ils sont
des secteurs qui sont plus en difficulté
et c'est vrai qu'on se dit là on en a
parlé dans votre portage quels seront
les critères c'est là où ça va être
sûrement assez difficile à définir parce
que tout le monde se remet Diara tel ou
tel titre ne critères ne va pas ou pas
bien à partir d'un moment on dit que la
conjoncture est bonne ou quoi par
exemple ça c'est très très compliqué et
puis ce qu'il faut rappeler aussi c'est
que normalement c'est un aspect
assurance une assurance c'est pas une
allocation c'est à dire que vous cotisez
pour cette assurance chômage quand vous
travaillez donc souvent ça on l'oublie
maintenant vous avez cotisé pendant des
années donc en effet quand vous avez un
pépin que vous arrivez quelque chose
même si la situation économique va bien
et bien c'est vrai que l'idée c'est
d'avoir cette aide et puis l'autre
élément dont parle aussi moins c'est le
capital humain pourquoi on fait ce genre
de choses pourquoi quand vous travaillez
vos cotisez et quand vous êtes au
chômage et bien justement vous aide
c'est pour éviter de perdre du capital
humain c'est à dire éviter que vous
preniez un emploi une qualification qui
soit en deçà de votre formation ou de
votre valeur ajoutée parce en effet vous
avez tel qualification vous faites autre
chose vous perdez aussi en termes de
valeur ajoutée donc c'est aussi pour ça
qui a été fait le système alors on
comprend bien ce qu'il y a derrière en
se disant bah là en effet il y a des
difficultés de recrutement donc en
faisant ça ça va créer des incitations
alors en effet ça peut le faire dans des
secteurs très spécifiques comme vous
l'avez expliqué mais pour arriver à ce
fameux plein d'endroit pleine emplois il
faut aller sur ces deux trois pourcents
de chômeurs et là vous avez vraiment des
gens qui sont durablement hors du
système de l'emploi c'est pas que
l'emploi qui pose le problème et donc ce
n'est pas en faisant ce genre
d'incitation que vous arrivez à mon sens
économiquement aller réintroduire ce
marché du travail
canadien est pas le nom de système
fédéral déjà
vous parliez des critères donc c'est
quoi une conjoncture qui est en train de
changer et puis même il y a la question
des territoires la Vendée est en pleine
emploi chercher c'est les
Pyrénées-Orientales qui étaient à 11,7%
de de chômage aujourd'hui on va pas
mettre un système
en fonction de chaque département enfin
comment ça peut fonctionner quoi alors
on pourrait aux États-Unis alors bah
c'est un peu plus grand mais ils font
par état effectivement c'est si le taux
de chômage dans votre état est inférieur
au taux de chômage moyen alors on durcit
on durcit les conditions et inversement
donc oui pas sûr que le Conseil
constitutionnels c'est un peu plus
compliqué effectivement et après c'est
est-ce que vous jouez juste sur la durée
voyez aux États-Unis ils font aussi du
contrat cyclique mais une on fait du
contrat civique aussi vous voyez quand
on a fait l'activité partielle c'est ça
quand ça va mal et ben on on aide
justement les entreprises et quand ça va
moins bien on arrête de les aider donc
on fait du contrastique quand on fait la
possibilité mais généralement c'est pas
effectivement comme il a été dit par
l'assurance c'est des aides publiques
c'est pas l'assurance oui là on vraiment
on est en train de changer complètement
de système et peut-être que c'est ça la
volonté au final je change un peu de
désolé mais de de la volonté du
Président c'est de sortir les
partenaires sociaux et aller vers une
assurance chômage complètement étatique
et ça sera de l'impôt à la fin et après
une fois que c'est l'impôt vous pouvez
faire tous les tout ou des aimants
contracycliques mais vous avez raison de
dire enfin ça va être quoi les critères
parce que on entend parler ici en France
d'un groupe d'experts qui désirait mais
oui aujourd'hui on est en haute ou en
basse conjoncture personne va vous par
exemple vous auriez du mal à répondre à
la question on aurait du mal à le dire
vous voyez autant on peut dire que là
effectivement ça va mieux mais demain on
parle de récession donc qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on change les règles est-ce que ça
s'applique sur la durée ou est-ce que
s'applique sur l'indemnisation oui
normalement on aimerait que ça soit que
enfin aux États-Unis c'est que sur la
durée l'indemnisation faut pas y toucher
parce que c'est ça important vous voyez
c'est une assurance je veux savoir moi
si je tombe au chômage combien je vais
toucher demain alors combien de temps
c'est déjà important mais si tout bouge
c'est à dire entre la durée et la
divisation ça c'est pas possible et au
Canada ils vont même plus loin c'est il
durcissent aussi les conditions d'accès
vous voyez là il faut avoir 6 mois
travailler six mois pour y avoir droit
bah on va durcir on va si je suis dans
un secteur en crise parce que vous avez
pas les territoires mais imaginons le
choix dans une conjoncture florissante
mais dans un secteur en crise ah bah là
j'ai la double peine c'est à dire que
non seulement je vais pas trouver parce
que mon secteur est en crise et on va
dire bah tu sais quoi on va durcir en
plus ces conditions donc c'est une bonne
idée sur le papier la contracepticité il
faut en faire mais pas au niveau de
l'assurance Bernard vivier qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez excusez
un point très sensible et très important
d'abord la question des chômeurs il y en
a dernier chiffre 2 millions 260 000
chômeurs ils ont peut-être d'analysés
chiffres de juillet dernier ça
représente 40% 40,3% du total des
chômeurs donc ça veut dire que 7,4% de
la population active mais
40% seulement du total des chômeurs ça
veut dire que c'est à dire qu'il y a une
majorité de chômeurs qui sont non
indemnisés
l'indemnisation on ne répond pas à
l'ensemble de la question la question
elle a été elle est vache c'est la
question de la formation la question l'a
dit aussi les conditions de travail du
logement du transport bon et donc ça
pose aussi la question de la gouvernance
les organisations syndicales vous l'avez
dit rechigne à aller dans la logique du
gouvernement
vous avez cité le secrétaire général de
la CFDT Laurent Berger qui a dit dans un
entretien tout récent ceci
si le gouvernement est dispose à
s'engager dans cette voie c'est à dire
avec d'autres d'autres critères que
l'indemnisation il dit banco nous sommes
prêts accepter une prolon une
prorogation donnant des règles actuelles
jusqu'à fin 2023 sachant qu'en 2023 il
conviendra de revoir le fonctionnement
actuel de la gouvernance et la question
elle est là l'action au chômage est née
entre acteurs du marché du travail
patronat et syndicat c'est en 1958 bon
et aujourd'hui
le dispositif a été
c'est presque un rap par la puissance
politique par la puissance étatique avec
on a vu tout à l'heure un extrait de la
réaction de du secrétaire national de la
CGT Philippe Martinez qui dit ce cadre
là cette loi cadre bah c'est un piège en
fait c'est tellement le cadre est
tellement petit qu'on peut pas on peut
rien négocier est-ce que c'est ça ce que
vous me dites le projet de loi qui va
être abordé demain aux ministres vise
simplement à repousser jusqu'à fin
200023 et la préparation de nouvelles
règles et c'est dans ce temps-là que
l'on va voir si la puissance étatique et
le président de la République
accordera ou pas un espace de décision
et pas uniquement de concertation le
monde négociation n'a pas de sens entre
l'État et les partenaires sociaux il y a
pas de négociation c'est une
concertation mais une vraie capacité
pour les acteurs patrona et syndicats à
gérer l'assurance chômage n'oublions pas
que jusqu'à ce que l'État s'empare de
l'argent de l'assurance chômage
l'assurance chômage a toujours été très
bien géré avec des réserves
considérables pour que en période de
difficultés économique il y ait de
l'argent pour financer les chômeurs
l'État comme dans de nombreux autres
domaines quelque part il y a beaucoup
d'argent et je prends la formation
professionnelle le logement les
personnes handicapées autant
d'initiatives créées par les acteurs du
marché du travail qui a été capté par la
puissance publique c'est pas Emmanuel
Macron c'est plusieurs présidents de la
République en arrière mais là il y a un
coût d'accélérateur assez fort alors on
a on a cité deux fois déjà Laurent
Berger je vous propose de l'écouter tout
de suite le secrétaire général de la
CFDT peut-être sur la philosophie de de
ce projet et puis il y a deux infos
intéressantes sur lesquelles on va
rebondir après écoutez ce qu'on nous dit
c'est en gros il y a des difficultés de
recrutement et pour faire face à ces
difficultés recrutement il va falloir
appuyer sur la tête des demandeurs
d'emploi pour qu'il soit un peu encore
plus sous l'eau parce que s'ils prennent
pas si on n'arrive pas à recruter c'est
parce qu'il y a des gens qui sauteront
indemnisés la plus de la moitié des gens
qui sont au chômage aujourd'hui ils sont
pas indemnisés et quand on est on
regarde l'étude atarès la DARES c'est le
l'institution de de statistiques du
ministère du Travail c'est pas nous hein
ils disent sur les difficultés de
recrutement c'est 30% parce que un peu
plus de 30% parce qu'on n'a pas les gens
formés donc vous pouvez réduire les
indemnisations chômage ça va pas vous
former les gens nous on pense que cette
mesure c'est une mesure idéologique et
dogmatique car qui est en rien efficace
et qui en plus est injuste on l'a déjà
évoqué mais je voudrais revenir quand
même sur la première affirmation de
Laurent Berger sur le la plus de la
moitié des demandeurs d'emploi ne sont
pas indemnisées Anne-Sophie alors ils
sont où ils sont où ils vivent de quoi
enfin pardon c'est des questions
ultra basiques mais on peut se poser
tout à fait bah c'est les fameux
chômeurs dont on parlait de personnes
qui sont très éloignées du marché de
l'emploi vous avez des gens qui ne
cherchent plus et donc du coup qui ne
sont plus dans le système et donc si
vous n'allez pas votre rendez vous etc
vous pouvez être après radié donc vous
n'existez plus donc là vous sortez
vraiment du système et pourquoi il
répond pas à cette demande d'emploi
qu'on voit parce que ils sont pas formés
parce que
alors ils répondent alors c'est là
encore je il y a une contradiction qui
semble évidente qui est peut-être
beaucoup plus complexe mais la question
de la formation c'est pas évident de
changer de secteur c'est vrai que là
quand on regarde les chiffres on se dira
ben voilà il y a des demandes dans
l'hébergement la restauration donc là il
y a des personnes qui ont pas d'emploi
pourquoi tout de suite ils n'y vont pas
on sait pas aussi simple de changer de
secteur et de formation il faut y avoir
accès avec ce qu'on voit avec la
formation c'est que c'est souvent les
personnes qui en ont plus besoin qui
n'ont pas accès justement c'est plutôt
les les catégories plus formées qui ont
ces formations donc vraiment la
formation c'est la première la première
raison et puis l'autre aspect c'est
vraiment en effet des personnes qui
cumulent pas que le problème
d'employabilité qu'on d'autres problèmes
sociaux économiques de logement et qu'il
a sont vraiment durablement sorti du
marché du travail et donc là c'est très
difficile de les réintégrer même si vous
avez une très forte demande c'est pas ça
qui va faire que vous allez réussir à
avoir ces deux trois points qui nous
manquent pour aller au plein emploi et
je vais vous poser une question avec
ailleurs qui a peut-être faire hurler
une partie de nos téléspectateurs mais
c'est pas grave je
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à cet
argument par des enquêtes peut-être bah
c'est sûr qu'on a toujours forcément
quelqu'un dans notre entourage qui
effectivement joue avec le système donc
on peut penser que c'est la norme bon
alors après il y a des enquêtes qui sont
menées d'accord la dernière enquête qui
est menée là-dessus c'est que
globalement sur les 100 chômeurs
d'accord vous en avez 86 % qui jouent
complètement le jeu donc vous voyez 14%
qui effectivement sont à la limite nos
recherches pas les emplois lorsqu'ils
sont et quand on ne regarde ça c'est sur
l'intégralité chômeurs là vous parlez
des chômeurs indemnisés
quand on regarde que les chômeurs
indemnisés faut que je me suis un
exactement du chiffre mais c'est encore
plus bas c'est une mémoire
5,4%, 6% allez on arrondit assez que 6 %
des chômeurs indemnisés ne jouent pas le
jeu c'est à dire que
94% joue le jeu donc vous voyez vous
dites on va faire des mesures pour
essayer de lutter contre ces 6% bien sûr
mais avec des effets de bord sur les
autres qui essayent de jouer le jeu qui
joue jeu d'ailleurs et on va leur dire
ben non voilà
on va un tout petit peu te pressoriser
et donc je pense qu'effectivement là là
dessus c'est important de connaître ses
effets de bord puisque ce n'est pas une
généralité il faut quand même faire très
attention une hypothèse qui n'a pas
encore été évoquée ici peut-être que
Pôle Emploi fonctionne mal peut-être
aussi que ces agences censés aider le
rechercheur d'emploi à trouver un emploi
adéquat sont surmenés il y avait des
enquêtes de faire bien leur travail ils
le disent qu'on vous allez au guichet
c'est vraiment un discours qui a été qui
a été d'ailleurs fait de façon tout à
fait publique dans des enquêtes dans des
livres etc ils sont débordés ils ont
trop de dossiers ils n'ont pas les
moyens de travailler correctement il y a
même des indemnisations qui traînent
parce que les dossiers s'accumulent
est-ce que France travail
c'est l'un des aspects de la réforme
marque est-ce que France travail
fonctionnera mieux est-ce que on va
uniquement changer le nom ou est-ce
qu'on va peut-être davantage mettre de
l'huile des rouages ça dépendra des
moyens qu'on lui aime ou j'imagine et de
la gouvernance
Pôle emploi c'est la réunion des Assedic
et c'est-à-dire la structure qui paye
les chômeurs et la structure qui a unepe
qui s'est forcé de trouver un emploi on
avait deux tuyaux de 10 l'un statut
privé l'autre statut public on en a fait
un gros tuyau ça c'est tout bouché ça
jamais fait un tuyau de vin donc c'est
ça quand on éloigne des acteurs du
marché du travail c'est-à-dire patronat
et syndicat le pilotage et bien on tombe
dans la bureaucratie et c'est ce vers
quoi on va cela étant sur la question de
des mesures incitait d'incitation je
partagerai pas tout à fait la vie ces
mesures sur l'indemnisation visent aussi
à pousser inciter davantage quand même
les chômeurs à retrouver plus vite un
travail
l'assurance chômage c'est une assurance
mais il est vrai et c'est pas uniquement
% que des personnes se disent bon allez
je vais attendre j'ai une longue période
d'indemnisation j'ai un niveau
d'indemnisation qui n'est pas
désagréable pour retrouver un emploi
n'oublions pas que le taux de chômage en
France a beaucoup baissé il est à 7,4
mais il est au-dessus de la moyenne
européenne 6 % les Allemands sont à
3% et les Britanniques à 4 donc on a
encore des efforts à faire et le marché
du travail aux États-Unis était
extrêmement fluide extrêmement rapide
alors le temps le temps file français le
temps file nous reste à les quatre cinq
minutes je voudrais qu'on parle de quand
même de ce chantier gigantesque air de
la de la transition écologique parce que
on peut pas parler de la réforme de de
la globalement de l'emploi en France
avec cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage sentais sans évoquer cette
question moi j'ai en tête le secteur
automobile qui passe à l'électrique avec
voilà des des formations gigantesques
des centaines de milliers de salariés
qu'il faut former parce que ce sera plus
le même métier la question étant de
combien de on en a besoin pour fabriquer
une voiture électrique par rapport à une
voiture thermique et il y a beaucoup
d'autres secteurs dans le même cas
comment
avoir cet objectif de plein emploi tout
en menant cette transformation qui est
majeure quoi qui rentre dans le business
model des entreprises non mais il est
certain qu'il y a des métiers qui
n'existeront plus de mains la transition
écologique et des compétences que l'on
n'a pas aujourd'hui d'accord et donc
pour revenir à quel est le rôle de pôle
emploi normalement le rôle de pôle
emploi c'est quand quelqu'un arrive il
doit se poser la question est-ce qu'il
est très proche du marché du travail
c'est à qui peut retrouver et donc là il
faut que je l'incite à y aller tout de
suite d'accord ou est-ce qu'il est très
éloigné du marché du travail et là dans
ce cas de figure là s'il est très
éloigné il faut au contraire que je le
garde que je le forme et pour le former
assez nouveau métier assez nouveau
métier mais sauf que pour que la
personne dise ok je veux bien être formé
il faut que j'ai une durée
d'indemnisation suffisamment longue
parce que former un nouveau métier de
qui est pas du tout le mien c'est pas en
six mois légèrement beaucoup plus long
que ça et il faut une indemnisation
importante sinon je dormais moi c'est
bien sympa une histoire mais j'ai des
crédits à rembourser et j'ai une famille
à nourrir donc je vais retravailler même
si tu me dis tu vas me revoir dans 6
mois je tente ma chance vous voyez c'est
il y a eu des prix Nobel en 2010 en 2010
pas la préhistoire c'est bizarre
Mortensen qui ont une prix Nobel
là-dessus en disant quelle est la bonne
durée d'indemnisation bah ça dépend
c'est pas ça dépend pas de la
conjoncture ça dépend de qui tu es situé
pas qualifié dans un métier qui est qui
est pas d'avenir il faut au contraire
que la durée d'animation soit longue
pour que je te forme et inversement si
tu es très qualifié dans un métier de
demain là il faut une incitation à
retourner très vite et là je peux te
faire une dégressivité s'il faut mettre
une dégrise mais Anne-Sophie est-ce
qu'on peut être à ce point à ce niveau
de pointillisme dans dans la
distribution de des allocations en tout
cas il le faudrait économiquement ce
qu'on va d'ailleurs quand même dans tous
ces débats vous l'avez dit dans vos
enquêtes sur la place du travail c'est
qu'il y a un côté quand même idéologique
et de stigmatisation c'est à dire que
derrière vous dites quand vous
travaillez pas etc vous travaillez sur
la collectivité vous profitez c'est mal
etc donc il y a des aspects moraux qui
n'ont rien à voir avec les fils
économique et qui sur ce sujet
malheureusement sont importants et font
que certaines politiques peuvent être
menées plus la suite que sur
l'efficience dont donc parler mais
justement quand on met en place comme ça
une réforme de l'assurance chômage on
constate qui j'ai l'impression que vous
les spécialistes vous n'êtes pas
consultés comment et comment comment
est consulté et derrière cette réforme
de l'assurance chômage il y a des
économistes connues et qui travaillent
sur des des travaux académiques mais
vous voyez c'est pas une science exacte
l'économie sinon ça serait donc il y a
des discussions un dernier mot Bernard
Huy il y a il y a une date vous l'avez
un peu évoqué mais j'aurais qu'on soit
précis pour notre téléspectateur il y a
la victoire du 1er novembre on peut
expliquer pourquoi rapidement sinon le
le la précédente réforme n'est plus
opérationnel c'est ça il y a un projet
de loi pour que les règles actuelles
soient prolongées jusque afin décembre
2023 ça ça va laisser le temps de de
mûrir de voir un dispositif aussi bien
dans le contenu que dans la gouvernance
et sur ce dossier la gouvernance
un peu un théâtre d'ombre mais
novembre pardon nous interrompre c'est
ça ce qui laisse pas beaucoup de temps
partenaire sociaux pour discuter on est
d'accord on met en place un dispositif
qui va permettre de se donner le temps
de réfléchir plus plus fortement
problème de fond c'est très est-ce que
l'État va dire aux partenaire sociaux
voici je vous donne d'ailleurs quelques
semaines ou quelques mois pour négocier
mais voici déjà la conclusion de votre
négociation c'est une conclusion une
négociation factice ou est-ce que c'est
voilà on va on va discuter aujourd'hui
le Pôle emploi c'est l'état la formation
c'est les régions l'insertion des
bénéficiaires des RSA c'est des
départements donc bien sûr il faudra il
faut réorganiser tout ça il faut surtout
donner aux acteurs du marché du travail
à nouveau le pouvoir accomplirant merci
beaucoup merci à tous à demain à vous et
à bientôt à vous sur ce plateau de
sciences publiques votre prochain
rendez-vous politique sur notre antenne
demain matin
[Musique]
Sébastien Chenu porte-parole du
rassemblement national belle soirée
[Musique]